in the early morning hours of June 27th
2013 team of Los Angeles sheriff's
deputies and detectives pulled up to the
property of 80 year old Eugene Malik a
retired engineer a man with no criminal
record a respected and politically
active member of the small desert
community of Little Rock California
he loved conversation would chat with
friends and even strangers for hours the
local restaurant down the street in fact
it was at this restaurant where he met
his second wife a woman more than 30
years his junior he used to come in
pretty much every night and order we
just kind of hit it off from the minute
we seen each other conversation just
joked with each other and I would sit
whenever I had extra time and just talk
to him because he just had all these
great stories and you were just drawn to
him don't get your breath all out Tonya
describes Eugene as a gentle giant who
lived a low-key quiet life but all that
changed the morning the Sheriff's
Department crashed through their front
gate and raided the property the
officers had pushed their way into the
front gate it looked like military cops
cuz they were just like they had helmets
he had a batter Ram metal and I'm big
big huge guns it just kept asking me do
you know of anything illegal here I kept
telling her no there's nothing here and
at one point she suggests there is and I
said what but then she wouldn't answer
me and I was like there's nothing here I
looked at Garrett and Garrett looked at
me like what is going on what the
officers were looking for was the most
villainized drug of our era mess we
never had no meth
don't do math it's just unbelievable to
me that they would even say that or even
think that this is the LA Sheriff's
Department executing a search warrant at
the time of the raid tanya was asleep in
one of the three trailers on the
property her son Adrian lived in another
trailer where Tonya's niece and her
boyfriend were also visiting a handyman
who often helped her on the property was
tinkering with a car slowly each one
emerged responding to the announcements
made by the police and one by one they
were each detained but Eugene was
nowhere to be seen
James was hard of hearing he would not
hear me if I was in the kitchen you had
to like be right like this for Gina here
you armed officers entered the house and
what happened next is where things get
murky deputies performed a knock a
notice on the kitchen door and gained
entry into this smaller cluttered
residence
Eugene Valeri exited his bedroom at the
22 caliber handgun extended out and held
up with both hands that was gesturing
that I you know he goes I heard five to
six he goes shots and I was like that's
okay it's okay
I got everything's okay no no no I just
didn't I didn't get it you know and then
he did it again real slow and I just
remember it just hitting me like
and I'm like oh my god something's
happened to gene Eugene Mallory died
within an hour six gunshot wounds all
fired by a single deputy who told the
coroner that Mallory had walked towards
him with the 22 caliber handgun extended
out and held up with both hands deputies
fired six times was dropped into the
bedroom floor the problem is when the
investigating coroner arrived on the
scene he didn't find Eugene Mallory on
the bedroom floor he found him on the
bed I came back to that bloody bedroom
you know there was blood just running
down the back of the bed and the covers
were just saturated in the thick thick
blood the mask that they put on to help
you breathe was just full of it and then
I was just sick
it appears the decedent collapsed near
the bedroom entryway and was moved by
paramedics to the bed prior to my
arrival but later that story changed the
officer who shot Mallory admitted during
an internal investigation that Mallory
was not charging at him but was in bed
at the time of the shooting before
listening to the audio recording the
officer believed that he told Mallory to
drop the gun
prior to the shooting the recording
revealed however that his commands to
drop the gun occurred immediately after
the shooting
Eugene Mallory never fired a single
bullet the deputy who shot him says he
removed the gun from Mallory's hand and
set it on a bedside table before anyone
outside the department
the police found no evidence of
methamphetamine production on the
property what they did find were two
juvenile marijuana plants grown by
Tania's son Adrian who holds a
California medical marijuana license how
is that a justification for coming in
and killing a man nothing was done
illegally here and now to justify it
through that through marijuana or
whatever they're trying to justify it
through is makes it even more wrong how
could a detective obtain a warrant
authorizing a raid on an 80 year old
man's property in search of meth only to
leave with a couple of marijuana plants
an anonymous informant tipped off a
detective Patrick Hobbs about the
property Hobbs a self-proclaimed
controlled substances expert surveilled
the property for four days I drove to
the location and drove around the entire
property
once I was downwind from the location I
could smell the strong odor of chemicals
I formed the expert opinion that the
location is being used as a clandestine
methamphetamine lab site the community
in general likes the police to a degree
but we keep a sharp eye on them because
they do new things they're outrageous
the LA Sheriff's Department has been
plagued by scandal in recent years from
its prisoner abuse problems to its
hiring of violent and dangerous
personnel and many people living in
these rural outskirts of LA County have
a deep suspicion in fear of them people
have again and again found that agencies
who are supposed to be serving the
people are actually acting in ways that
are oppressive to the people a lot of
people have encountered these things and
it's a pattern and practice it's not an
isolated thing by any means the US
Department of Justice is actively
investigating Antelope Valley unit
regarding allegations of systematic
harassment and profiling of minority and
low
some residents tanya has filed a
wrongful death suit against them but she
knows that all the money in the world
isn't going to undo her husband's
violent death a must know some but don't
say nothing we just keep rolling he
keeps on rolling along he's on plant
cotton man that plantain is soon
forgotten
no man river they just eat